according to the agenda we're now about
to honor what has been called the
world's loneliest professional those men
and women who sit staring out of windows
pacing the floor of their cubicles or
mumbling in desperate tones to
themselves there are the screenwriters
and without the product of their
loneliness all of us would be lonely for
we can do nothing until they've given us
words which of course we change this
bitter observation was written by one of
them and I didn't change a word to
present the next Oscars here are two
artists who make any writers words sound
better
former Oscar winner Miss Joanne Woodward
and mr. George Peppard
thank you I've never changed so the
writers words have you George
certainly not let's begin yes because of
our respect for our office we are
pleased to present the screenwriter
excuse me
instead about a respect or please
wouldn't a privilege to be better
provision about honor we are honored to
present the screenwriting award
the best screenplay based on material
from another medium the nominees are
Walter Newman and Frank our Pearson for
capital ooh Stanley man and John cone
for the collector Robert bolt for dr.
Zhivago
Abbi man for ship of fools herb gardener
for a Thousand clowns Joanne will you do
the honors the winner is Robert vote for
dr. Zhivago
excepting for Robert bolt mr. David Lean
I'm terribly terribly pleased to be able
to accept this for Robert he had our
most fiendishly difficult job and we
wouldn't have got the brass to date but
for him thank you very much
but the best story and screenplay
written directly for the screen the
nominees are Jordana RG Capelli mario
monicelli
Tonino Guerra JoJo's alveoli and sister
checked EADS amico for Casanova 7 de
Grazia photography Alfred darling
that's all he works alone
Jack Davies and Ken Anakin for those
magnificent men in their flying machines
Franklin Cohen and Frank Davis for the
Train Jacques Demy for the umbrellas of
Cherbourg the winner please this is your
turn
winner is Frederick Rafael for darling
something for Frederick Raphael honey
Steven
original screenplay writing I think is
still a very foundation of the motion
picture industry on behalf of mr.
Raphael thank you very much I'm sure
he's very honored